Did you get ups?
I mean when,
when you went over and got into a fight with Leon,
you were being interviewed,
he was yelling some shit at you while you're being interviewed and you walked
over.
And one of the,
one of the things that I like what you said is that you walked over your hands
behind your back.
You're like,
look what talk,
say what the fuck you want to say to me.
But then when he was standing in front of you,
like you wanted to punch you,
you're like,
okay,
well you know for stuff.
Was he saying to you were initially,
um,
I was doing my interview and he's crossing by and he's with his corner man.
And I dunno if this guy consumes a lot of drugs or what,
that he thought that that would intimidating muse.
He was walking like this looking at me and like pacing back and forth and I'm
trying to do my interview,
you know,
and he asked me something about something,
a date and I say maybe,
maybe not.
And then he tells me to shut up,
you know.
Well,
everybody watching this back home from Miami was like,
you should've punched him as soon as he asked you a question while you're
interviewing,
because that's my natural inks thing.
You know,
if you're getting interviewed and some fucking idiot comes here and cut your any
rear off,
well you should get punched or slapped upside your head.
You know,
that'll teach you respect none to do it then nobody else again,
I should immediately done it,
but I didn't.
I answered this question,
but lightning,
maybe,
maybe not.
He goes on to say,
shut up after that.
I can't take that.
My daughter might be watching this interview.
I've been telling her,
stand up to bullies your whole life.
Don't go running to somebody and tell them,
oh,
so and so's picking on me.
Handle it yourself.
That's what's wrong with this country.
I think with this whole,
somebody picks on you.
Go tell somebody else.
I'm not going to tell authorities this hooligans picking on me.
I'm going to handle it myself,
you know,
cause I'm going to see him again.
He's going to think he could pick on me.
I've got to handle it myself.
You know,
I'm in my interview,
man.
You're gonna steal my moment.
I just worked out here.
Just kicked some butt out here.
You barely want to split decision in your own country.
I knocked this dude out and you're trying to steal my shine like this.
That's what I'm saying.
Like,
and then he got famous off that which I hate.
So only thing I could take back about that night,
that it wasn't filmed that and filmed it,
it'd be even better.
You know,
he was just gone off in silence.
neon got his ass.
That helped you to know did it help me out?
But it helped him more than anything.
Yeah.
No,
it helps.
Yes.
People know who the school knows.
Mossville doesn't take any shit that people known that since before rainbows had
color.
They already knew that man.
They didn't,
they didn't need to see you whooping 10 I know that.
They like to see it.
They'd like to get remembered,
Huh?
Yeah.
They like to see people have consequences for shit.
Talking in this weird era of constant shit talking,
you know,
I think people enjoy it.
They like it.
And if you guys ever fight,
it makes it a bigger fight for sure.
I guess,
let me guess,
but does that like I beat number three,
I've been in this sport for a while and beating up guys,
would that validate them to fight when he has some beat in the top 10 guy yet
still yet to be the top 10 guy you know like,
but he could get that fight off that.
That's the new age and era that we're in.
I know,
right?
That's a concern.
I'll fight when when his,
when he's beating in the top Tim got,
I'm going to be the first guy to expose him to break his face.
But until that moment comes you're,
you're talking about the business side cause you already saw on the personal
side any day of the week I will address you but on the business side,
get to my level buddy,
put in the fucking world.
Go beat a top 10 guy,
knock him the fuck out.
Did you talk at all about getting in trouble for punching somebody in another
country?
I was scared out of my fucking life.
That's what I'm thinking.
I was scared.
I thought this guy was going to kill me,
man.
I might've not looked at,
but I was scared out of my life.
Yeah,
I get it.
I'm very cold blooded.
You know I get that from,
from genetics,
from my pops in them.
But I was scared at that moment.
I thought this guy was going to take everything I had,
you know,
had to do that.
I had to defend my Saturday.
I understand,
but did you worry at all about them arresting you or any weird shit like that
over there?
I mean,
you're in another corner to press charges.
Ah,
I,
that's how scared I was.
But I'm not going to press charges because I understand.
I'm a man.
But that's how I felt.
I've seen you were in danger.
I was fucking hell of in danger.
Do not see.
It was not just one say it.
And he that him and his crew of hooligans,
hooligans,
lawless people.
I had to defend myself.
I did everything in my right to defend myself.
It was one against like three or four dudes and they know it.
Yeah.
It's something video that,
okay,
I understand.
And so the,
with the police say to that,
oh,
they ain't telling me nothing man.
They didn't tell you shit.
I didn't speak to know polices.
That's amazing.
No,
no police for me not talkative anyway.
I've been the Spanglish immediately.
We go on mute and I enough to get English gay,
pick English.
I mean,
how many times he fought in England before the war.
First Time.
So like if you go the rest of your career,
you can't go to England.
Oh,
well no,
that was,
I really liked England.
Did you?
Fans are so knowledgeable and they were just cool.
Even the ones who were like,
till fans would say like a funny joke to me or something cool.
But it wasn't like that weird bad energy,
you know,
even if there were till fans,
but just get out,
my boy tils are going to get you,
you know,
but it'd be like funny and how they say cheeky,
was,
it was a great experience.
Everywhere I went.
The people were super,
super duper cool.
Yeah.
Um,
Brazil's rough.
If someone's fighting a Brazilian,
yeah,
they,
they don't.
I've heard the story that I've yet to find a solution for nationalists that can
proud,
very proud.
So they're not into people coming over there and fight Brazilians.
They're not going to be friendly to you,
but ain't guns different about,
they're very polite.